why do you want this job so I can walk
by hello exactly that's why anyone would
want a job if you were an animal what
kind of animal would you be
Oh Oh wah wah se ha ha
a pterodactyl I feel the same and one
final question am i convincing as a man
oh great
it's me Mary I'm just playing sorry I'm
sorry to trick you like that but you
were amazing seriously you could get any
job you want and then we'll go get ice
cream I will share it no need to be
nervous
Sam I actually have a look we went to
summer camp years ago she might not
remember me but if I remember her she
was a very classy ladies
okay take a seat this interview started
so I was looking at your resume and you
used to be an art appraiser we just
quite look like totally useless
what you do here is we make drinks sell
drinks by using sexuality oh girl your
God what are your strengths it was a
little mill okay wow you're gonna fit in
perfectly here okay we could use another
BFF gal here so if you were in the major
motion picture movie Jurassic Park what
animal would you be
okay so if you were having to deal with
a bar fight how would you handle that
you need to leave right now
it's a liability yeah see you there
crazy
Wow
find an M&M McFlurry please
John's gonna be so mad
hey everyone thanks for watching episode
5 of sim Meets World I hope you had a
fun time subscribe to my channel and
I'll see you next Friday for the next
episode of sim meets world bye guys have
a great weekend